right tonight a brand new scandal
involving anti-trump FBI lovebirds Peter
Strucker and Lisa Paige newly obtained
text messages between struck and Paige
are revealing damning new information
now struck we find out today as friends
with Federal Judge Rudolph can
terrorists who sits now on the FISA
Court now the romantically involved
trumpeter struck and Paige also message
about attending a cocktail party with
this judge judge Contreras now here's
what is really disturbing the judge
presided over the hearing when
Lieutenant General Michael Flynn pled
guilty to lying to the FBI
now there's a lot of other important
context to explain here we'll do that in
just a minute but first let's take a
look at these brand-new text messages
let's start July 25th 2016 Paige writes
Rudy the judge we're talking about is on
the Foreign Intelligence Surveillance
Court did you know that
and Paige adds just you know appointed
two months ago struck replies I did and
we talked about it before and after I
need to get together with him so struck
and judge Contreras know each other now
Paige later writes it's as a read
through this thought of it because you
had to Google Foreign Intelligence
Surveillance Court judges and saw him
there I'm telling you
struck follows up with well she brought
up a good point about being circumspect
in talking to him in terms of not
placing him in a situation where he'd
actually have to recuse himself and
Paige then text I can't imagine either
one of you ever talking about anything
in detail meaningful enough to warrant a
recusal and Paige says well anyway maybe
he didn't mean to but didn't and struck
answers really Rudy I'm in charge of
espionage for the FBI any espionage FISA
comes before him what should he do given
his friend oversees them Paige replies
to in this particular case standards for
cues although are quite high I just
don't think this poses an actual
conflict and he doesn't know what you do
and then struck responds yeah generally
doesn't know what I do not to the level
of the scope or area but he's super
thoughtful and rigor
about ethics and conflicts I'm
suggesting a social setting with others
would probably be better than a
one-on-one meeting I'm sorry I'm just
gonna have to invite you to the cocktail
party you can sit next to me I'm adding
that part then struck continues of
course you'll be there have to come up
with some other work people cover for
action and page rights why more 6 is
perfectly fine for a dinner party Oh 6
intimate setting they know each other
he's in his position the judge in his
position there's a lot to unpack here so
what is clear is that Peter struck new
the judge and that both he and Paige
wanted to attend a party with him that
is a massive conflict of interest
engineering a meeting with a FISA judge
under false pretenses in this case a
cocktail party that could actually be
obstruction and of other criminal
liability well ask Gregg Jarrett in a
minute what is really inexcusable is
that the Department of Justice fought
like hell especially rod Rosenstein to
keep this information secret now Sarah
Carter reporting the congressional
investigators working for congressman
Jim Jordan congressman mark meadows they
discovered these text messages at the
DOJ headquarters and this is part of the
outrage according to Sarah Carter of the
1.2 million documents the DOJ Inspector
General has acquired the House Oversight
Committee has only received just over
three thousand quote unique documents
that means the DOJ never ever wanted the
stunning information to get out they've
been trying to hide it remember back in
January the Deputy Attorney General Rod
Rosenstein begging in the final hours
before they had to turn this information
over begging Speaker of the House Paul
Ryan allow the DOJ not to turn over the
documents related to the Russia
investigation to Devon Nunez and these
congressional committees it's now clear
why rod Rosenstein yeah that guy that
appointed Muller now did this it's all
part of a year-long pattern of
obstruction of stonewalling
non-compliance in Congress's efforts by
the way in constitutional duty to
investigate and oversee the access at
the DOJ
you know it's called checks and balances
think about this for a second if rod
Rosenstein had his way we wouldn't know
about any of these scandals people now
need to be held accountable this is why
people like Oh Grassley and Tillis and
Cornyn and Graham are demanding as we
have been demanding for a year aspect a
second special counsel to investigate
the investigators they can't investigate
themselves now as for that very
important context we learned that struck
and judge Contreras or friends and that
judge Contreras oversaw the Flynn case
which after he accepted the plea it was
a mystery why did he then recuse himself
now we still don't know the exact reason
why but this could have something to do
with it we also know that Peter struck
was the FBI agent he oversaw the January
2017 White House interview of lieutenant
general Flynn and here's what we really
need more information on struck is the
former FBI counterintelligence official
who signed the paperwork to start the
entire Russia investigation and as these
new text messages revealed judge
Contreras was on the FISA Court and
sources have been telling us that judge
Contreras may have signed off on one of
the FISA applications to approve the
warrant to spy on Carter Paige Trump
associate which means the Trump campaign
which likely gave the FBI access to
trump campaign communications this is
stunning it is corrupt it is an abuse of
power and it shows inexcusable biases
and conflicts of interest that the
Department of Justice has tried to
conceal now we need to know all the
communications between struck page and
Contreras as a matter of fact release
all the struck page content text
messages everything you got we need to
find out if struck was involved in
putting together the FISA application
for Carter page he was a former high
ranking counterintelligence official he
was bragging about it now the FISA
warrant for page was signed in October
2016 struck was fired from Muller's team
in August of 2017 so it is time for
struck to tell us what did he know when
did he know how does this guy have a job
and don't forget Lisa page was of
Andrew McCabe and we did also reach out
to judge Contreras for comment he didn't
get back to us and also breaking right
now USA Today is reporting the Justice
Department is considering publicly
releasing parts of the FISA surveillance
order against Picard a page how about
releasing all of it now this would mean
we would get to see exactly how that
fake news dossier the bulk of which was
used to get the FISA warrant against
Paige was used and how the FBI misled on
purpose purposely omitted information to
FISA judges about Clinton that she
bought and paid for that fake news phony
Russian dossier and also tonight a
significant new development speaking of
Christopher Steele Fox News Tonight
reporting a British Court is now
ordering steel to sit for a videotaped
deposition as part of an ongoing legal
battle against BuzzFeed the website that
published the fake news dossier now to
call this huge is a massive
understatement
now steel will likely be forced to try
and verify the dossier that he infused
in GPS and the FBI never verified never
corroborated so in other words steel
will under oath have to admit whether or
not he knew the dossier was full of lies
from his phony Russian sources but gave
it to the FBI
anyway and according to a new book
Steele told friends that it was kind of
50/50 about the most salacious part of
the dossier that's the part that
involved the hookers at the ritz-carlton
urinating on a bed and we also have
learned more about Steele's use of
current and former Russian government
sources we're gonna be following this
story very closely all right but also
breaking right now new details on the
timeline for former deputy FBI director
Andrew McCabe to be fired and lose his
pension now we're learning that the
deadline could now be Saturday and as we
have been explaining the fact that
McCabe is even in this position is
stunning it is inexcusable
he means he did something drastically
radically wrong our sources are telling
us that McCabe could end up facing
multiple criminal charges forget about
the pension
and just a few months ago mccabe was put
on leave after current FBI director
Christopher Rea was reportedly informed
that McCabe was going to be exposed in
the upcoming inspector general's report
I can't wait for that report and also
tonight as we have predicted for months
the disgraced former FBI director Jim
Comey he's prepared to cash in on his
newfound fame I did predict that you
know in just a few weeks
Comey is gonna kick off his whirlwind
book tour
he's got tough interviews with Stephen
Colbert
Clinton sycophant George Stephanopoulos
and a cozy sit-down with the ladies of
the view and according to a new report
from Axios Kobe's planning to quote come
out hot and correct all the so-called
lies about him in the FBI for months we
have literally been bringing you the
American people on a nightly basis
breaking news hard-hitting investigative
reports about the corruption at some of
the highest levels of our government
including the shocking details about the
abuse of power at the very top of the
FBI now James Comey you want to come out
hot you want to answer hard important
questions you're welcome on this program
tonight I am officially opening up an
invitation to Jim Comey you want to sell
your book come on the show will give you
a full hour you name a day we'll make it
work we'll work with your schedule I'll
give you three hours on my nationally
syndicated radio show which by the way
is on 575 radio stations around America
so everybody can hear from you and we'll
ask you the tough questions the ones
that Stephen Colbert might miss for
example did you in fact tell a close
session of Congress that you believe
Michael Flynn did not lie to the FBI did
you think he's being unfairly prosecuted
why did you draft a letter exonerating
Hillary Clinton of charges in the email
investigation months before she was
interviewed by the FBI and 17 other
important people and will you explain
the lies in the omissions to the FISA
Court and why did you tell Trump that
the dossier was unverified and salacious
three months after you allowed the same
dossier
be presented to the FISA Court when you
didn't tell the FISA Court Hillary
bought and paid for it and you knew that
why did you withhold the fact that
Clinton paid for the dirty dossier and
how do you explain your unlawful leaking
of classified information to the media
after you were fired you know through
that Columbia professor you wanted the
Special Counsel Jim Comey if you're
looking for fame and fortune you want to
sell books by all means have fun on the
view have a great time yuk it up with
Colbert hang out with George
Stephanopoulos go get a beer afterwards
but if you really want to reach all
Americans defend your honor if you
really want to tell the truth we've got
a lot of questions for you come on this
show a full hour three hours of radio
that's the best deal you're gonna get
we'll lay out all the facts we'll lay
out all the evidence we'll give you a
chance to respond and as we say here at
Fox
well we report we'll let our audience
decide if you're telling the truth